the story is from Politico Biden bashes
oil sector for war privateering and
warns of windfall tax on profits you
know what that means right
if they put a tax on the profits for gas
companies what do you think is going to
happen the price of gas is going to go
up yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna punish them for
price gouging All of You by charging
them more money so they'll be forced to
increase the prices is that what you're
saying yeah people people you know need
to understand gas is higher in some
places than other places because of the
gas tax of the government already taxing
it the government could make gas lower
by just not taxing it but now they're
deciding we're just gonna tax it even
more which is absolutely ridiculous I've
heard that oil companies have been
maintaining record profits uh oil
companies get record profits amid Global
crisis August 11th what is it what does
that mean record profit 55 billion this
last quarter between and what's epx on
Chevrolet
no no no no hold on hold on 55 billion
in profit yeah okay I'm not I'm not a
fan if they're raking in the profits at
a time of Crisis but hold on what was
their total revenue
uh what was what was the gross revenue
uh to profit and then last year and the
year before I wanna I wanna know their
total profit to total gross revenue you
know why because of inflation yeah right
so they could say it's a record profit
yeah because inflation is up 10 so they
got 5 billion more than they got last
year does that mean the buying power of
their profit is the exact same but the
number is larger because Biden's because
of bite inflation this uh from the
guardian shows that Exxon made second
quarter profits 17.8 billion four times
the year before so their their second
quarter profits were four times uh in
one year we did not have four times
inflation I have a feeling that these
companies are spiking the deal that
they're taking advantage of it for sure
because I see Biden begging them to
lower their prices on Twitter and
they're just like we don't have to but
um but it's not just these companies
it's also Saudi Arabia it's also Russia
it's also a lot of other you know
countries that produce oil
plus Biden shut down Keystone and banned
fracking on certain lands so if he
really wanted to get things down he
could be increasing competition and he's
not absolutely yeah if you really want
to harm the energy companies increase
the domestic oil supply and that's you
know increased exploration that's
reduced regulations if you want to make
them have fewer profits then you know
increase competition exactly because if
you add tax to the gas company taxes and
you can't make them set their price I
mean can you legally in the United
States make a company set its price
price that's very communist you could do
that in Venezuela because it's a
communist so that's that's referred to
as price fixing it wouldn't be legal
that's what they did to toilet paper in
Venezuela yeah and that's why you can't
get toilet paper I don't know a whole
lot about Brazil's politics but seeing
you know Lula win made me kind of
worried because it is a lot of I don't
know man I don't know enough about
politics to say too much it probably
would not be fair for me to comment but
bolsonaro's out he's out and I look at
stuff like this and I'm like people were
all like Trump is bad and then they vote
for Biden but it's like I'm gonna make
your gas cost 10 times as much and here
you go right well Lula is another world
economic Forum member so I'm sure Brazil
is going to be uh you know protecting
the globalist policies uh that of course
are pushing the UN 20 30 30 Vision so
Russia's all let me sell you our gas
through the Mediterranean United States
and United States it's all nah
nah can't nah don't don't compute nah
and Russia's like yo let's be trade
partners and they're like
is this still people are afraid of
Communism like they're afraid and but
Russia is Russia's not communist it's a
federation and there and the U.S seems
to be buddy buddy with China at least in
a lot of regards I should I should say
Democrats like Biden are which is fine I
want to be trade partners of China and
Russia I think the three countries can
run the world together you know and then
we'll spread American republicanism
ideally they but they disagree with you
the Chinese Communist party is is
worried about American republicanism so
they want to crush it
so what do you do I saw a video out of
Brazil
um you know it could have been fake but
I think it was it was really there were
multiple videos I think I know what
you're talking about yeah it was
um a recording of a major prison in
Brazil of the prisoners celebrating as
they received the news that this you
know Lula whatever his name is uh
defeated bolsonaro because they know
that this guy is a left-wing radical
he's a jailbreak Justice type of guy
yeah and they know that their sentences
are about to become a lot lighter yeah
there's allegedly a lot of gang members
um in the favelas shooting off guns and
celebrating as well allegedly that's not
a good sign and he was charged with he
was he was convicted of corruption or
something it was like stealing millions
of dollars
amazing but look man that's par for the
course down there to be honest but not
just that I mean even the United States
you have people who will vote for John
fetterman right his brain is is busted
and I feel bad for the guy man but he's
not all there and they're people who
vote for him the same thing is true of
Joe Biden there are people who hate you
so much they would vote for a ham
sandwich if it meant you suffered that's
a great point and it also shows to the
left they view their political leaders
as just merely vessels for their
ideology you know that you know Joe bid
I mean Joe Biden's dick manager in Chief
and everyone can see plain as day that
he is mentally incapacitated doesn't
matter he's just he's a vehicle John
Federman I mean he could be the ideal
U.S senator for the left he's just you
know he's an empty vessel he can he can
you know he'll vote yay or nay the way
they want to every single time that's
perfect for him and that's just that's I
think that's that's a hard pill for a
minute to swallow is that that's that's
where we are as a country that's where
our political system is we have one
party that in this cycle could
potentially elect someone who is you
know a walking Bears report
yep man that's brutal and fetterman
meant you know he he and we can't talk
about why he's in this condition can we
well we should because he lived across
the street from a steel mill but we can
talk about it on the after show if you
want to really get into it fair enough
but he had a stroke in May and now the
timing of that was interesting and and
he's unable to effectively communicate
and they argue that it's just his
auditory processes but I he clearly
can't speak and they lied about that
dude I watched an interview in his house
it's echoing booming echoes in his house
because this is wide open they have
wooden floors it's just constant sound
just nailing him he went that sound
messed that guy up he took he took the
steel mill from across the street
breathing in all that carbon oh man John
well people in this country are willing
to vote for as you said empty vessels
but I but I think it's it's not just
that they're going to vote yay or nay as
they want it it's that they will they
they hold in their hearts the same level
of hatred for you
Joe Biden going out on TV and saying the
Maga Republicans are an extremist threat
he hates you as much as all of his
voters do it's like their only policy is
we hate you and we want you to suffer
that's it now they'll argue that's what
Republicans think and there's probably a
lot of Republicans that are you know
probably doing that way I don't know I
think the Republicans are fairly bad in
a lot of ways but you sit down here and
we talk with some of these various uh
politicians and they will articulate
their positions about why they want to
do what they're doing
and then you you take a look at the
Modern Democrat narrative and its Maga
Republicans are evil right it's like
well when we talk about like child sex
changes we have very real real concerns
we can easily articulate what's wrong
with it they'll just say but you're a
racist you're a bigot you you you're
transphobic like not even give you an
argument they just don't like you
exactly and and we on the right are so
unprepared to deal with that ideology
they're not interested in debate we we
wrap ourselves we I think we we kind of
make a uh a lower G God out of our
intellect out of our ability to
rationalize whereas the the opposition
they don't care about that no all they
care about is crushing you yeah and you
know they don't care like that's the
whole Ben Shapiro thing like Ben Shapiro
you know will will Dazzle you with his
intellect but when you're when you look
like like their feelings don't care
about your facts so so so how are you
prepared to defeat that more importantly
Ben Shapiro actively tries to have
conversations with people he disagrees
with and come to an understanding and I
respect that but they don't care right
they don't care they're going to vote
for John Federer well so I think the
best example is we will invite them to
sit down here and express themselves and
they will say no
every single libertarian traditional
disaffected liberal and conservative
will say anytime let me know when but
the Democrat left is nope no dice and
even even when I talk to them on the
street they'll be like uh delete that
delete that recording you can't use it
it's like bro you're in public you
walked up to my camera that's not how it
works we've had we've had a couple so it
happened to me I felt the story but
we've actually had some instances for
timcast.com where people are like I've
changed my mind and it's like dude you
said in public in front of everyone what
you said like we you walk up to us we're
filming it you can't come later but I
revoke consent to being filmed I'm not
sure if you guys saw it was Matt Walsh
he was doing a speech and he this young
trans it was a man I I don't know what
gender the person was but they were
trans and they were they were talking to
Matt and like I don't know what to do
you say these things I'm upset and I
don't want to put words in their mouths
you should watch the interview it's
great and then Matt was like I don't
just I don't hate you I love I I want
the best for you I'm angry with these
pharmaceutical companies selling
medicines for profit that haven't been
tested and telling people that they're
that they're safe this is the test run I
care deeply you could see like he really
cares about these people yes that was an
example of someone from the left
expressing their emotions and someone
from the right understanding and
communicating in their language and an
emotional way yeah all but also
displaying some facts about the
pharmaceutical companies sure and I saw
that that was very powerful and you know
it's a great example of you know the the
the
you can't have and ultimately you know
quote free market because that's a great
example is these you know quote gender
transition uh you know genital
mutilation treatments I said treatment
they're just barbaric procedures in
Arkansas you know we we had a state law
that was passed that would have outlawed
them for minors uh our Republican
Governor vetoed that legislation we
overrated that's there's there's that's
the rub you know he is a you know
Republican governor of a deep red State
an R plus 30 State this is Arkansas and
the Republican governor vetoed the
legislation and um you know that that
law got passed it was overridden that we
we overwrote his veto in the legislature
but that law there was a big lawsuit
which is still ongoing and you know the
plaintiffs in that lawsuit trying to
stop the law from being implemented it
was you know all the uh you know medical
associations the University of Arkansas
for medical Sciences Walmart the Walmart
Foundation
um the Arkansas Chamber of Commerce you
know like all these big you know
entities
um you know I would just like the the
globalist for lack of a better term you
know they're against it and so you can't
say that word anymore now remember who
said that so there was this actually is
uh uh I don't want to derail you though
if you want to finish your thoughts no
no that was really we're we're we're
powerless right now to stop that from
happening even in deep red States and
that's that's hard for us to swallow
they started this campaign that actually
started I think in like 2018 against
Alex Jones that globalist is
anti-Semitic and then people are like
but what do I say to describe someone
who wants a one world government and
they're like you can't
it's anti-semitis like what are you
saying about Jewish people yeah right
right I said internationalists there's
nationalists and there's
internationalists internationalists care
more for international relations and
community and nationalists care more for
their nation and Country
name calling in general is looked down
upon don't call don't slander globalists
yeah it's not name calling it's a
description of an ideology I think
globalist is a good time I just use
Google but name-calling people is like
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there